hmm
[Music]
up
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
let
i am so excited to show you what we've
been working on for the last four years
marvel snap is the culmination of
everything we've learned about making
super fun card games combined with the
power of the marvel universe it's been
an unbelievable honor to work with
marvel and new verse on our first
project there's never been a game like
marvel snap and we're so excited to
share with you
marvel snap is a collectible card game
where we stripped out all the stuff that
gets in the way of fun and gets
everybody straight into the strategic
action
the first thing that makes marvel snap
different than other ccgs is how fast
the games are this game is about three
minutes both players play simultaneously
there's no waiting we've taken your
opponent's turns and your turns and
layered them on top of each other so
that you don't have any waiting it's
just your turn your turn your turn your
turn you get to make all the decisions
in half the time
with marvel snap we really wanted to
bring it to the next level another
example is deck building once upon a
time card games had 60 card decks you
could play four copies of any card which
is actually just 15 unique cards and so
in marvel snap we thought hey what if we
just did 15 cards and actually the games
are so fast we can go down to 12 cards
which is still about the same amount of
strategic depth but it's so much easier
to build a deck
the game is all about the cosmic cube oh
snap in the rank mode you're basically
fighting against other players trying to
get more cosmic cubes
if you think you're going to win you can
snap your opponent and that doubles the
stakes
the whole mind games aspect does spike
my heart rate a little bit when you feel
like you are going to
win the game you can double down and get
more rewards back which feels great when
you win if you retreat game that means
you lose again but it doesn't feel bad
it's kind of like a skill for damage
control
it's played over three locations and
your goal is to win two out of the three
locations so the mind games start to
happen as you start shuffling your cards
around and trying to figure out how to
outwit your opponent to secure two out
of the three locations
the cards focus on the heroes and
villains of the marvel universe and
every card in marvel snap has a unique
ability these powers really affect the
game and so choosing the cards that work
best together is one of the most fun
parts of the game my favorite card is
probably magic time doll viper galactus
gamora king the conqueror
the marvel universe and marvel
multiverse ultimately is so rich how can
we get all of that into this game and
the only way to do that is through these
variants maybe you really like one style
of variant and so you want to collect a
bunch of them and build your whole deck
using these variants we'll find like
really unique artists who have such a
distinctive style that we actually want
to turn into a variant set so that's
another way we approach variance it's
another way to express yourself in
marvel snap so when we launch there'll
be well over 150 base cards for players
to collect and then we're going to
continue to be adding new cards to the
game every single month as these new
seasons roll out we just really want you
to see that there's gonna be something
new in there every day it's really
important to us that you're not paying
for power the game is free to play and
you can get every card in the game over
time without paying anything got em
we can just hit one button and you're
right into a game we try to find a fair
match for you there's no pressure on you
to figure out what kind of battle you
want to have today
the skill cap is really high i think you
can play the snap for thousands of hours
and not feel like you've perfected it
when no game feels the same you feel
like you're always learning i think
that's really important for a game
feeling like it has meaningful depth
we have huge ambition of constantly
delivering new content and constantly
evolving the matter for the game frame
break that will deliver better
experience to our players
[Music]
marvel snap is a mobile first title but
that's not the same as being mobile only
we are working towards having an early
access version available on pc at the
time that we launch globally
one of the things i'm most excited about
in the game are these incredible
3d effects that we have on cards they
really make it feel unlike any other
card game
[Music]
we did a lot of vfx around communicating
an ability for a card but we also
started adding flavor effects that just
make cards feel more like who they are
those characters
the music especially brings together
some of the iconic feel and genre that
you come to expect with marvel any time
a marvel character has an iconic line we
made sure to record that character sang
that line human torch says flame on in
the thing says it's clever time
marvel snap is like a continuation of
the fandom that many of us have had for
marvel since when we were tilers now we
get to pour all that batch into
something that's really going to make it
out there on marvel snap i get the
luxury of doing what i love and what i
love is art you just geek out over the
comics that you used to read as a kid
and spend every day looking at something
that is going to blow your mind it's
just a dream come true
we hope you enjoyed that first look into
the passion and excitement we put into
making marvel snap it's been an
incredible journey thanks to our
partners at marvel and newbers for
helping us get all this together and
follow us on our social media tick tock
facebook twitter everything and go to
marvelsnap.com sign up for the beta it
starts soon we'd love to play some games
with you thanks for watching everybody
[Music]